dans la vallée de la békaa le paysage et
verdoyant en grande partie grâce à la
culture du cannabis une culture illicite
au pays du cèdre
mais qui fait vivre plus de la moitié de
la population locale depuis plus d'un
siècle
[Rires]
90% des gens ici vivent de la plante du
haschich
ils ont de bonnes maisons aujourd'hui
ils peuvent éduquer leurs enfants les
envoyait l'université dit le maire de
chamonix
sans l'apport économique du cannabis et
la production du haschich les habitants
de son village aurait bien peu pour
gagner leur vie raconte le maire partout
dans le village les petits producteurs
safer transformer la plante récolté à
l'automne pour en revendre le produit à
des trafiquants l'odeur terreuse a créé
citronnée à la fois embaume les rues les
fermiers et leurs familles se protège de
la poussière en couvrant leur visage ce
qui garantit aussi l'anonymat qu'ils
exigent pour nous permettre d'observer
leur travail illégal le gouvernement
libanais veut maintenant légalisée et
encadrer cette culture qu'il n'arrive
pas à endiguer le cannabis pourrait
devenir leur verre qui sauvera
l'économie en difficulté du liban espère
le ministre de l'économie et du commerce
ça pourrait rapporter des centaines de
millions de dollars de revenus au
gouvernement et en même temps créer des
emplois pour les gens de la bécade
ministre dans les banlieues aussi ou
peut pousser cette plante le liban soit
autorisé son usage médical seulement
afin de promouvoir la mise en place
d'une industrie pharmaceutique
l'idée a germé dans un rapport d'une
firme d'experts étrangers commandé par
le ministre de moi que les anglais de
pau tarbes et le marché afin dit-il
le potentiel est très grand il ya de la
place pour tout le monde en ce moment
pour les producteurs de haschich d
amener ce serait une bonne nouvelle la
fin espère t-il d'une vie en marge de la
société
à la condition que tous ceux déjà
recherché par la justice libanaise soit
amnistié avec une nouvelle loi entre 30
à 35 mille personnes sont recherchées
dans la vallée de la bekaa part
pas au haschich dit il tous ces gens ils
se cachent ils ne peuvent pas se
présenter dans les points de contrôle
ils ne peuvent pas se rendre dans les
villes la plupart pas sa vie dans les
montagnes mais des organisations qui
oeuvrent sur les problèmes de dépendance
aux drogues voit d'un mauvais oeil les
ambitions économiques du gouvernement
la consommation pourrait augmenter en
flèche craint l'organisation mentor
surtout chez les adolescents à cet âge
le cerveau se développe et a besoin
d'une pleine activité de toutes ses
cellules dit il
le cannabis est un effet direct sur les
cellules ils peuvent aussi développer
une tolérance au thc
ils ont développé une dépendance wissam
samat ne crois pas que le gouvernement
du liban puisse assurer les contrôles
nécessaires
les exemples de pays étrangers ne
peuvent pas s'appliquer au liban selon
lui le canada n'est pas corrompu comme
nous le sommes dit il
selon le nouvel index publié par les
nations unies le liban est dans le top
10 des pays corrompus
nous ne sommes pas fiers mais c'est la
situation actuelle au pays
aujourd'hui le liban est l'un des cinq
premiers producteurs mondiaux de
haschisch selon des chiffres non
officiels
le trafic de haschisch représente un
chiffre d'affaires de 4 milliards de
dollars sur le marché noir
c'est environ 4 fois plus que ce que les
calculs les plus optimistes promettent
en revenus pour les coffres de l'état
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada 0